at what point does the safety and the
health of a lot of people get dictated
to by a group of other people it's a
fundamental question for the public
health of the country the treating guns
like a public health issue would be a
relief smart move for America well
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special I am really excited
to welcome to the set Piers Morgan you
know him of course from our infamous
interview set on CNN but also he's of
course the host of good morning Britain
on ITV and he's a columnist for the UK
Daily Mail you can check out all of his
work at Daily Mail Dom Pierce thanks so
much for stopping back I would say the
pleasure but let's see how I go too
hasty here well I mean I do have to
start off by thanking you we have 100
employees and at least I would say 50 of
those will probably due to the fact that
you had me on your show really nice and
on Twitter the clip you know where I go
off to you about your little book being
the Constitution just to clarify for
your for your listeners in your viewers
I meant the physical size of the book
and I promise we will gets it for all
the viewers will get to gun control a
little bit later the reason I don't want
to start with that is because we could
do that the entire hour and then we
rehash all the stuff that we've done
before plus my audience knows your
position on gun control your audience
I'm sure knows my position on gun
control but I promise we'll do a little
bit later on a start off with asking
sort of what is your background so for a
lot of American viewers they first
became familiar with you when you were
on CNN or when you're on America's Got
Talent you've done this wide variety of
stuff so what was your pathway to
celebrity effectively I was a journalist
so I trained as a journalist in England
and I they go on to various newspapers
national newspapers after a full
training on local newspapers and I
became at the age of 28
the youngest newspaper editor the
Britain had seen of the news of the
world Rupert Murdoch's biggest selling
newspaper in Britain so that was my big
break I owed it to Rupert very much he
took a big gamble on me and then after
two years I defected to The Daily Mirror
which was the slightly left-of-center
tabloid up against Rupert Murdoch's son
in Britain we have as you may know
ferociously competitive newspaper
marking tabloid there I've always said
doesn't mean tabloid like National
Enquirer tabloid it means probably New
York Post New York Daily News kind of
battle that was going on and we were the
slightly left to centre version of that
so I then ran The Daily Mirror for 10
years producing three and a half four
newspapers in that time and then I got
unceremoniously fired over a scandal
involving photographs of British troops
apparently abusing Iraqi civilians it
followed the Abu Ghraib scandal here in
America very soon afterwards and to his
day I don't really know what those
pictures were or how we came to publish
them other than we did it in good faith
country to mythology I didn't
deliberately publish fake pictures my
own brother is a British Army colonel he
was on the front line in Basra at the
time so a very very difficult situation
for me I was the editor of a paper that
opposed the Iraq war and then got fired
over an element of that so I was then
thrown into the wilderness of having had
a big job and suddenly like I lose
everything quite sobering for a few
minutes then quite like liberating that
I was like okay I've done 10 years
chained to the desk of this newspaper
I'm now gonna go and try the things and
I tried a few different things then
Simon Cowell rang me up and said I've
just sold the rights to a show called
Got Talent
a new show that he created to NBC and I
need somebody to be a judge when they's
gonna be as arrogant and as obnoxious as
I am and I can't do it because I'm doing
American Idol and your name is
immediately sprung to mind
I got parachuted out here I literally
flew out the next day met NBC executives
who've never heard of me had to give
them the full Morgan cell which
you yourself have heard many times and I
got the gig and three weeks later I
began on America's Got Talent which gave
me for the first time a profile in
America and I did that show for six
years I then did Celebrity Apprentice
which is another NBC show at the same
time I was doing Talent and of course
Donald Trump was the host I ended up
winning that first season of so birdie
apprentice and that also probably more
significantly in the long term developed
a friendship that I had with Donald
Trump which is lasted to this day then I
joined CNN as you know because you were
one of my repeated repeat guests
actually several times and and it was
always good television and I did nearly
four years of CNN and though I think
Americans got pretty fed up with me and
I got pretty fed up with Americans and I
went home and
back to cricket and mushy peas and
proper beer you know the warm kind and
and watching and playing cricket and
that was it
would be a good thing for all of us have
a little break from each other so in a
second I want to ask you about the sort
of nexus between celebrity and
journalism because you got to experience
both in the United States obviously for
a lot of folks who saw you on CNN and
didn't know of your history in Britain
it was like why is the guy on America's
Got Talent suddenly doing a journalist
thing when the truth is that obviously
had a long history as a journalist
before that so and asking where you
think the proper blind should be drawn
between celebrity and journalism and
particularly in the United States where
it seems to have merged first if you've
been watching how central banks have
been manipulating our currency you know
I'm talking about the Chinese currency
the American currency it makes you think
a little more about investing in crypto
and blockchain I know these sound like
they're something weird but they're
really not all they are are a form of
currency that can't be manipulated by
central governments last week China
devalued its currency and markets tanked
one consequence was that Bitcoin prices
actually rose it might be time to
seriously consider including some crypto
in your portfolio the best place to
trade crypto is eToro eToro is smart
crypto trading made easy eToro social
trading platform has over 11 million
active traders and facilitates over 1
trillion dollars in trading volume per
year globally you can access the world's
best crypto currencies they have 15
different coins available low and
transparent fees you can try it before
you trade with a virtual portfolio with
100,000 dollar budgets he can find out
how it works never miss a trading trend
with charts and pricing alerts as well
sign up today at eToro dot-com slash
Schapiro that's ETO
ro comm slash capiro eToro dot-com slash
Schapiro let's talk about the merger of
celebrity and journalism so obviously
you know there are a lot of us in the
journalistic space in the United States
I'm an opinion journalist so I get to
give my opinion for a living but
journalists have now become celebrities
in the United States and in your case
from American eyes even though you were
a journalist first it was a celebrity
becoming a journalist do you think
that's good for the country well how do
you think journalism should be done
since you've experienced in my case I
was certainly a journalist as far as I
was concerned I didn't get to CNN job
because of my ability to judge piano
playing pigs I got it because I run a
daily newspaper for ten years and they
knew that I also in Britain had an
hour-long
primetime interview show which had been
run
for a few years which was very
successful so they saw me interviewing
world leaders huge stars and so on that
was really why I got the CNN job it
wasn't America's component that was
profile to go with the the back catalog
if you like
I think the interesting relationship
between celebrity in the media goes back
a long way it goes back to probably the
late 60s I think when newspapers
suddenly in embraced all things
celebrity and they began to put
celebrities on the front pages if you go
back to look at newspapers 50 60 years
ago you wouldn't find many celebrities
on the front page you certainly wouldn't
see a news agenda driven by celebrities
so the world of celebrity became much
bigger through that period then you had
the internet in the last 20 years
propelling everyone into Andy Warhol's
world of 15 minutes of fame if you like
he can be famous for anything you can
kill someone and be famous particularly
in America I think where there's such a
huge media and such a huge volume of
stuff in the ether the noise if you like
and if it's allowed celebrities to be
journalists and journalists to be
celebrities honestly I think that there
are good size to that and bad sides the
good side is that if you become a
celebrated journalist well more people
will listen to you and if you're a good
voice an important voice in American
popular culture I think that's good the
bad side is you can see now that I think
a lot of people who should be impartial
journalists and masquerade is impartial
journalists are now drifting towards
being celebrities and right now in
America in trumps America the only way
to be a celebrated journalist is
predominantly to be a liberal Trump
hating journalists and that's where it
gets dangerous to me when I look at CNN
now for example when I was there the
standards and practices around
impartiality were extremely extremely
rigorous reinforced you could not
remotely be seemed to be looking like
you were impartial you were partial
politically now I look at it I just see
open sneering at Trump 24/7 and I like
it well things have changed because when
I was there you couldn't do that and I
think that's problematic
America needs CNN to be impartial you
know you have MSNBC on the left you have
Fox on the right people have always
understood
that if CNN itself becomes partial and
partisan I find that a big problem I
find it a problem with some of their
reporters want to be big stars
you know anchors they're gonna be stars
because they're anchoring but when
you're a White House reporter or
correspondent you really should be doing
the late-night chat shows I don't think
so
so I think that there's a line there
which is getting crossed more and more
which which i think is a problem for
American people and their ability to cut
through all this and get to the truth
yeah I mean as I'm fond of saying ladies
fine to use somebody who loves you like
Jim Acosta loves Jim Acosta it's in it
and I like Jim Acosta taken me wrong and
he's a very good correspondent he's a
very good on-screen reporter do I want
to see Jim Acosta doing books about
Trump while he's still president and
he's still reporting on him and then
going on a you know he came on good
morning Britain fine no problem and a
good interview with him it's just I
don't think that's probably what he
should be doing and I don't think it's
what CNN should be doing and I say that
as a somebody who likes CNN and has a
lot of friends there but they have gone
so partisan that it you know what
happens at the end of all this once
you've basically abandoned your pretense
in partiality where does it leave you
afterwards and for the American right I
think the critique actually does predate
the Trump era I really you know object
to that there's this characterization
that President Trump by ripping on the
fake news media that he was the one who
collapsed trust in the media and if you
look at the polls that really isn't true
particularly on the right my parents
cancelled the LA Times back in the 1990s
because they were detecting bias in the
way that things were being reported and
that does raise the question as to
whether we should even be aspiring to
objective journalism or whether we
should sort of go back to the original
at least in America the American
partisan model that was sort of
prominent at the founding of the
republic are they holding your hands up
and saying I'm a I'm a partisan
journalist right I'm coming at this from
the right or I'm coming at it from the
left I have no problem with that I've
got no problem at night flicking between
Fox and MSNBC getting a bit of Rachel
Maddow and getting a bit of Tucker
Carson or Hannity I think it's healthy
to get both these probably unhealthy if
you only watch one of them all the time
because they're coming at it from a
skewed position and they will see the
news through their own lens if you see
both lenses you can I think work it
for yourself if you've got a half a
brain so I agree that it's been around a
long time I have never known it like it
is now and I think it's being massively
exacerbated by social media which has
turned this bait I think you've touched
on this yourself many times you know it
feels like we've gone back 2,000 years
and we're back into tribes you know you
have it with Trump here in America where
it's just blind you know you you have to
be in one tribe or the other you're not
allowed actually to say well on the one
hand I think he's doing some good things
here here here on the other I don't like
what it's doing here
it's everything about this man and
everything he does and says every time
he breaks wind it offends me right or I
love him and everything he does is
fantastic even when Trump does something
ridiculous and I know that you you know
you actually have come through as as I
think a pretty reasonable voice in all
this and I've tried to be that you know
checking you know found common ground
you know you were saying you've read
most of my columns and you kind of 75 80
and I I find myself looking your Twitter
feed and not being offended because I
think we both come at it from the same
mindset which is actually the most
important thing is to you is to maintain
the ability to have a democratic debate
with people and to better sit with
people that you fundamentally don't
agree with and to listen to things you
find fundamentally offensive but
actually respect someone's right to
think differently to you and again
coming back to this tribal thing you
know if you go back 2,000 years you'd be
in your tribe you would never venture
outside of your the confines of your
tribe and you all dress the same you
thought the same you behave the same and
that was the accepted way that you
believed existence occurred and then as
you began to move out through the years
and you began to encounter other tribes
they dress differently they thought
differently they behave differently and
the tribe the original tribes only
response to this was to find them so
terrifying these people they had to kill
them and the other tribe felt the same
way I look at social media some days now
and you know I'll give an example will
come to this I'm sure but the recent
horrendous weekend of my shootings in
the you know you go about 30 years if
that had happened in America we
of any politics I think the country
would have had a pause it would have had
a pause where that kind of tribal
partisan shrinking was just put on hold
to actually pay respects to the people
who were killed and their families and
the first responders and so on this time
literally could count the seconds before
the whole thing had to play out as a
tribal politically partisan debate with
fury behind it on both sides and I find
that a really insidious and unpleasant
facet of modern debate whatever your
debate yeah there's no fundamental
assumption of good faith that takes
place and I'm not even talking about on
policy I'm talking about on basic
humanity so it turns into as I've been
saying all week on my podcast about this
this should be a moment where everybody
goes okay at least we all agree that
white supremacist terrorists are evil
right and instead it turns into no
you're in league with the white
supremacist you actually are a white
supremacist or conversely you want to
take all of my guns and there's no point
at which anybody actually just stops and
says no actually this this thing here we
all agree this is evil let's figure out
some ways to deal with it
instead we immediately go to how can we
beat each other up over I think Twitter
has been awful for this of all the
social media sites I think Twitter is by
far so many ways but I think in terms of
embedding these tribes into these
mindsets it's been horrendous it's like
the boom box I mean I must grab that is
the boom box from the hook remember this
there's you know the beginning of a hook
we're gonna take a pirate and like you
admit that you did something you made a
boo-boo and now we just throw you in the
boo box and we throw scorpions and
snakes in there until you repent yeah
and that's what it is and everybody
spends their five minutes in the boo box
once every couple of weeks and trends
sounds whether you've been through it
I've been through it it's really ugly
but it's the inability to have a debate
without wanting to cancel people to
wreck their lives to make them lose
their jobs all that kind of thing you
know there's no platforming phenomena
which has now come to Britain you know
we now have this no platforming thing
where someone like Jordan Peterson is
not allowed to speak it can be
University for God's sake I mean what is
happening in the world when somebody
with that kind of mind you know in many
ways a brilliant mind I don't agree with
half of what he says perhaps but I
thought you can see he's got a brilliant
mind he likes to challenge people's
thought process make you think what is
the point of being at university if
you're not going there to
be challenged and to have your own views
challenge and to have people you don't
agree with I mean that's the whole point
of it isn't it
and yet now suddenly unless the guest
speaker I'm sure you get this all the
time it's nonsense you know Bill Maher
was no platform from Berkeley I mean for
God's sake Bert it was the home of free
speech I required six hundred police
officers I think it burger utterly
ridiculous this was the place where each
free speech began in the 60s you know
the kind of campaigning for it and now
look at them now you need six hundred
police officers to protect you why what
are you to do to these people
you're not going to commit a violent act
against them you're going to express
your opinions and you knowing you as I
do we'll enjoy the two and throw of them
coming back at you and say Ashley
Shapiro here's where I think you're
wrong
and having a debate it's called
democracy so where do you draw the line
with regard to the First Amendment aux a
lot about the Second Amendment before
between the two of us obviously but the
First Amendment obviously Britain has a
slightly different standard than the
United States the United States is very
free and very open we have much more
lacks standards when it comes to libel
and slander and also we don't have any
restrictions on so-called hate speech
which Europe obviously has attempted to
put restrictions on where do you stand
on that particular debate well I think
that any hate speech which actually acts
as a catalyst of people to commit acts
of violence to me is unacceptable
wherever you are on the world you know
well in statement is illegal under the
First Amendment it's an actual legal
standard you have to incite violence it
can't just be something that you got and
somebody yeah what yeah right what is
more problematic for me in Britain for
example the libel law is incredibly
draconian and the onus is on the
publisher to prove that what they
publish was 100 percent true it's not on
the onus to the person who is suing you
to prove that it's wrong now that sounds
like okay fair enough until you get into
the weeds of what that really means you
know I'm as a newspaper editor I used to
publish stories I knew a hundred percent
were true could I actually prove it in a
court of law when somebody sued us
sometimes that would be impossible
even though we all knew the story was
true that wouldn't happen in America in
America would have to be not just
publishing a story even if it was
completely wrong you would have to prove
malice was there
from the intent in other words it was
deliberately designed to damage somebody
that's the difference in Britain that's
not the case at all and I think that we
have a far worse all-encompassing free
speech environment in my country than
you do in America so you know in our
battles over the Constitution a lot of
the US Constitution I think is extremely
solid not least the First Amendment if
you remember when there was a petition
that be deported from America started by
our old friend Alex Jones of Infowars
and it was signed by 150,000 people so
it was a White House petition which
meant the White House had to respond
because it passed the threshold Barack
Obama and she saved me for the American
people there was a bit of a shock to the
American people but he did and he cited
the fact that under the First Amendment
I was entitled to comment however
egregiously to gun lovers in a negative
way about the Second Amendment and
they're right there was an example that
I went through of the power of the
American Constitution and the right to
freedom of speech so I understand rights
in America and a lot of them might
completely agree with which do you think
is healthier the British media ecosystem
or the American media ecosystem because
it is very different I mean I've
experienced both sometimes for good and
sometimes for bad obviously I think we
the advantage we have in Britain is that
we have certainly in television terms we
have two 24-hour news networks which are
completely impartial the BBC and sky sky
which was until very recently was owned
by Rupert Murdoch could crated it and
for all the aggro that he gets over here
in America for supposedly partisan
supposedly obviously Fox News is make
idli partisan in many ways in terms of
its right-wing coverage and his
newspapers have been accused of that too
there's no doubt that in Britain the Sky
News is a completely impartial
broadcaster so the Brits have an
advantage in the sense that we have at
least two places to go the only cable
news if you like that we have is
completely impartial the only rolling
24/7 news networks that we have are in I
mean is that true about the BBC and
putting aside my own now how do you have
a perceived liberal bias and there's no
doubt if you shot a harpoon around the
BBC newsroom you wouldn't catch many
right wingers that is true
I watch it all the time and I believe
it's it fundamentally at his core
it's an impartial broadcaster in my view
so I think we're fortunate in that
respect I know Americans know who watch
BBC America because they want to get a
completely unvarnished opinion of what
is happening in their own country and
understand that it's very hard when
every news network in America now is
biased it's hard where do you go for
what you believe is genuinely unbiased
opinion now not opinion but news news
and I think it's important to have that
amid all the obviously opinionated and
either side these are being put out
there so in just a second only ask you
about chief topics for a second to ask
you about President Trump obviously
you're friends with him and he is the
news not just he's in the news he is the
news now we'll ask about that and just
one second first you know whenever
there's an emergency here on the news
about how people can't get to the
supermarket now some people are left
unprepared well don't be that person the
government warns you whether you talk
about an earthquake or a tornado or a
hurricane or some man-made disaster
you're gonna need something to protect
yourself in terms of food at home wise
company takes an innovative approach in
providing dependable simple and
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
wise company meals are designed to
protect your most valuable asset your
family when government resources are
strained it could be days if not weeks
before you can get some fresh food and
water you saw that in Puerto Rico you
can't rely on someone else you have to
rely on yourself you can't know what
tomorrow may bring but you can have some
peace of mind knowing that you'll be
ready with everything you need there's
no better time to prepare than right now
wise emergency food is an investment in
peace of mind for your family this week
my listeners can get any wise emergency
or outdoor food products at an extra 25
percent off the lowest market price at
wise food storage comm / apparel plus
shipping is free Wise has a 90 day no
questions asked return policy so no risk
in taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family more prepared today
that's wise food storage calm / Shapiro
to get any wise emergency or outdoor
food product at an extra 25% off plus
free shipping so let's talk about your
association with president ribs he
became friends with him when when you're
on Celebrity Apprentice I've met him
briefly before and she on America's Got
Talent he came on as a guest one day and
I had a little chat with him in a
he knew all about Donald Trump and in
Britain there was this great
larger-than-life character then I go on
somebody apprentice interesting things
for me with that show was that I day one
I met him and he came up to me he went
yo-you Rupa's guy right he used to work
for the murder I went yeah he said you
were like he's younger zetas or
something I said yes sir
okay then he must be smart you must be
spying like you know I was laughing go
okay not to a good start
host of the show legs are smart and also
read out of the deal free time so I
began to play the game exactly and I
thought Trump would play it and began to
talk to him almost like Trump which was
definitely a successful strategy but
what I remember being struck by it's
interesting one that he was over the
hundreds of hours I spent with him in
that boardroom is three or four hours a
session and you see you know no one can
cheat who they are for hundreds of hours
and I'm quite good at you know being
perceptive about human beings through
all my journalistic training over the
years I saw a guy that was clearly very
smart much smarter than I think he's
pretty giving credit for very charming
in those boardrooms aside I do not see
enough of as president he's come in he's
decided to play the white white white
president because he's getting wacked
all the time and almost it brings out
the worst in both him and his critics I
think if you read out of the deal his
whole strategy to people that criticize
him is to punch him ten times as hard
that's what Donald Trump's DNA is about
it was very successful in real estate it
got him elected president I would like
to see more of the charming Donald Trump
but I saw in the board room I think it
would go a long way if he just gave us
more of that so you know I find that a
frustration to somebody who genuinely
likes him personally but I also saw
somebody very decisive pretty solid
judgment he fired all the people I would
have fired he was very good though at
also creating a lot of controlled chaos
he liked people crashing together and
arguing and all that kind of theater and
drama all the stuff we see play out now
every day and his presidency he he
definitely enjoyed that he likes
conflict and he thrives off it you know
Donald Trump if you asked you would say
I'm sure he's at his best when he's
under fire the problem now is that he's
doing a half years into his presidency
and every day
it's a fire it's a fire fight and I'm
not sure the American people are being
well served by this and I don't blame
just Donald Trump I blame everybody the
media is now is predominantly a liberal
media and they just like poking the bear
and the bear likes swatting them back
but in the middle of all this of the
American people and they're like every
day just seems so dramatic rather than
actually can't be just get some stuff
done here amid all the shrinking and the
punch ups I mean in terms of the
interpersonal my theory about him has
always been because I grew up in
Hollywood that he's basically a
performer meaning that he is great with
people who are in the room and you see
when he's doing a live speech that he's
playing off the crowd in a way that a
stand-up comedian would play off the
crowd not like a normal politician plays
off the crowd and that means that he's
mainly appealing to the people who
really are almost literally within his
eyesight that that playing to the people
who are out there beyond the scope of
the camera it almost doesn't seem to
occur to him that there are hundreds of
millions of other people who are
watching this in a way that it might
have occurred to him doing The
Apprentice where it's explicitly a
product that is made for hundreds of
millions of people to watch and is being
edited in the background also I would
say that his strengths are often his
weaknesses too you know the unfettered
insight into the American president in
real-time on Twitter is fascinating and
and really riveting on occasion but he's
also obviously can be very damaging and
destructive as well you know he told me
that he likes to wake up in the morning
he sees all the TV screens he doesn't
like what he's seeing he just gets up
does a tweet and watches it all change
in real-time
change is the new agenda with his own
hand with his thumb boom if I was his
opponent or if I was one of the
Democrats running against him I
certainly wouldn't run a strategy of
just screaming abuse about Donald Trump
it didn't work for Hillary Clinton it
won't work for any of the candidates
this time the only way you could beat
Donald Trump is to play your own game
against him not the one he wants you to
play he wants to suck people into a
punch show it's where he feels more
comfortable you know he will always
justify his actions good bad and ugly by
the number of people that attack him
he'll say well look at these people you
know they're attacking me left right and
center why shouldn't I take them we all
know that's what he's like so as the
mede
I think you have an option the
collective media do we spend all day
attacking this guy hoping that he reacts
is that really in the best interest of
how we cover this presidency given
that's what we know he's liked and I
think at the moment it's like like
they're in an abuse relationship the
media and Trump and it's ugly and I
don't think it works for the American
people I think too much important stuff
is getting forgotten about you know
every day the only story is Trump every
newspaper front page every news bulletin
every cable news show it's just Trump
Trump Trump Trump Trump other things are
happening in the world and we have the
same thing in Britain with brexit see it
becomes all pervasive all dominant it
sucks the life out of everything else
and it of course fuels the tribes that
we talked about earlier I mean on the
other hand is is it the case that if
you're a Democrat you're looking at this
and you're feeling like the American
people are sick of the chaos suburban
women aren't don't like president
Trump's personality they feel he's too
abrasive all I have to do is basically
sit here and be a human and I have a
good shot at winning or do you think
that Trump is too aggressive for that
absolutely
he's Godzilla you'll destroy them you
can't just be mr. nice guy or miss nice
guy forget it so I'm gonna happen you
know I watch all the candidates that the
Democrats and apart from the absolutely
pretty suicidal strategy of allowing the
squad Alexandre Kaiser Cortez and her
friends are sucking the party so far
left they've become completely
unelectable if a completely unpopular
within their own party if people forget
that the squad is not popular amongst
Democrats nevermind anybody else how are
they possibly in a win as a party if
that becomes the face and voice so what
does Trump do he goes after them because
he wants them to be the face of voice
and the challenge for Democrats I think
in this election if they were really
want to beat Trump is they have to
forget that noise and they have to make
themselves the face and voice of the
party and they have to offer a vision
for America which resonates in a better
way than Trump's making America great
which by the way was brilliant marketing
now Trump at his heart is a marketeer I
don't think he has many ideological
bones on his body
but he's a brilliant marketeer and as we
saw last time
a phenomenal campaigner and yes it
really stopped campaigning
he's down doing rallies every week
massive rallies huge Turner's have you
see the video sometimes they're going
around the blocks these people will come
out and vote then you know his approval
rating is nudging up so I'd say to the
Democrats yeah you can all scream and
shout and lie on the floor you know they
have these sort of anniversary parties
don't they on anniversary of his
election but you go and lie on the floor
and you scream at the sky as if somehow
this is gonna beat Donald Trump he wants
you to do that you're all falling into
his trap and I look to all of them on
the on the debates the other day the
Democrats and I thought who's who could
stand there against Trump and beat him
possibly Biden I've always felt that he
would have been a better candidate for
them last time I think he would have not
made the mistakes that Hillary made he
seems to be gathering a bit of momentum
now but all the others you look at them
you think really you're gonna beat him
Kamala Harris or you know Marianne
Williamson or any of them really I think
I can't see you beat him and ultimately
politics is about power if you don't
have the power you can't change anything
so you can bang on about changing the
world but if you don't get power and
wrestle it away from Donald Trump you
are powerless so the current strategy
that the media and the left seem to have
about Trump for two years it was that he
was a Russian stooge then the Muller
report came out and that of course
completely collapsed in on them which
massively helped Trump
so the media's ridiculous over obsession
with Russia collusion which turned out
to be complete nonsense actually has
just fueled Donald Trump and made him
more popular because it looks exactly
like he's been saying the fake news
media making something up about me
screaming about it for two years and
when it all turns out to be nonsense and
yet you know in that Muller report there
were genuine questions about potential
obstruction of justice and stuff but as
I said to people imagine if you're down
in Florida or Texas in your thinking
hang on this this guy was accused of
something he didn't do and now now
apparently the really bad thing is that
turned out to be untrue is that he was
trying to obstruct justice into
something he never did how does that
work now we know how it works legally it
does work legally
you can't obstruct justice into
something you didn't do but in terms of
the noise around the Muller report and
what that did for Trump massively helped
him so I say again to the media who you
helping here by going so ridiculously
over-the-top on such meager scraps in
the way that they did and you know what
it was bent they wanted it to be true
so badly that they all forgot about
being journalists and it was hideous to
watch and they all got the the
punishment they deserved which is egg on
their face in spectacular form but more
importantly they've helped Donald Trump
just as they all helped him before well
without any shift in time they
immediately moved into the secondary
narrative which obviously has been
promoted thanks to the write the actual
very real rise in white supremacist
violence in the United States
that Trump is a racist that he's a white
supremacist that he's egging all of this
on where do you come down on this
question because this is the the
question of the day is Donald Trump a
racist is he a white supremacist is he
hugging it on and they may be three
separate questions I don't think he's a
white supremacist and I don't personally
think he's a racist because I've seen
him interacting around a lot of
non-white people in my time and I've
never got a sense at all of him having
any issue in terms of being in his heart
a racist however and it's a big however
he knows his base likes it when he fires
up racially incendiary comments at what
point if you say enough of them do you
actually lend support to the theory that
fundamentally you've become racist that
you're using racism for votes oh you're
using racism to make yourself popular
with your base and that's where I've got
a problem with Donald Trump and what
he's been doing when he said to miss
Omar
go you know go home that's a racist
comment yeah he can argue the semantics
to the cows go home it's a racist
comment to say to somebody who is an
American citizen go home and he doesn't
mean America and yours need to do it the
squad is inflammatory enough and helpful
enough to Donald Trump politically
because they're so far less and they're
getting so much oxygen of publicity he
doesn't need to play that card with them
but he did and when he does that I
I cringe if you think he's doing that
out of stratagem this does come back to
a question that you or you were speaking
to before
yeah there's two theories from the right
the theory is that everything he does is
40 Ches underwater upside down Hungry
Hungry Hippos every move is planned it's
all part of a grand game that he's
playing and on the left it's that he is
a simultaneously an evil genius and also
a complete who doesn't know what
he's doing
stumbling around in the don't think any
of those things but I do I think he's
capable the same ironic things
absolutely do I think he's capable of
saying things which are in my opinion
racist yes do I think it is heart he's a
racist no I don't I definitely I think
he's a white supremacist do I think
white supremacy is a problem in this
country absolutely there is clear and
cogent evidence that it is a rising
problem in exactly the same way that it
was a problem with Isis and that
ideology fueled by Internet fueled by
people sitting in their homes you know
reading and watching all this stuff late
by infiltrating their brains you know
one of the big issues I think right now
is how people's minds are being
permeated and influenced by the Internet
it's a huge problem I have got family
members and friends on Facebook
we've gone nuts about brexit or Trump
I've had to unfriend them unfriend your
own family right in some cases because I
can't deal with the kind of ludicrous
stream of consciousness that comes out
of their out of their fingers on their
social media and it's driven very
deliberately by groups who have a vested
interest in this and it's a very big
problem you know it you know you have a
you have a really important influence in
this country now you're able to get to
millions of people with these shows it's
why I've come on because I know how big
your your podcast is and congratulations
but and the reason I've come on is I
think actually amid all this noise
you try and be balanced and you try and
listen to alternative views but you're
in the minority most people out there
who are doing the kind of thing you're
doing are hyper partisan and they're
having it whether it's people having an
effect on Islamists who want to cause
carnage or people who have white
supremacist sympathies who want to cause
carnage
what is driving is they're getting
influenced their brains are getting
damaged and in in a matter
you could add the massive overmedication
as a potential factor in all this you
have 80% of the world's painkillers get
bought and used in America 80% of the
world's painkillers what is going on
that what's going on is this country is
being massively overmedicated and you're
getting young kids whose brains are
getting flipped they're reading all this
stuff online are they genuinely white
supremacist are they people attaching
themselves to white supremacy is
something to somehow filter their hatred
I don't know the answer to that but I
know it's a real problem and it's a
problem being fueled by the Internet it
does feel like a lot of the militating
social institutions have dissolved that
all of the places people used to go to
meet each other and hang out in real
life are gone I mean there's a poll
recently that said a plurality of young
people say they have no friends which
means that they're looking for some sort
of connection online and it's not hard
to find connection with pretty terrible
people online in the absence of that
you're gonna find the tribe I mean
you're gonna find whatever tribe most
allows you to gravitate toward it so
you've had a really interesting sort of
path on brexit so originally you were
anti brexit now you say that if you came
up for a vote again you would vote in
favor of brexit so where do you come
where is that coming from well mine I
think my position embrace it was it was
the referendum which caused brexit to
happen was driven by David Cameron but
then conservative prime minister from
pure political expediency there was no
real reason for the referendum other
than it suited him politically he
thought it would empower his position
and his party's position to finally deal
with this issue once and for all the
European bubbling away for a long time
so he calls a referendum in the certain
beliefs that he would win it never
crossed his mind he would lose it we'd
have the Scottish independence
referendum just before briggsie and he
led a very successful campaign to make
sure that Scotland stayed part of the
United Kingdom so you know David Cameron
was pretty confident that with brexit of
course we'd stay in the European why
wouldn't we but what do you
underestimate it exactly as I think the
Democrats underestimated here was that
there are now basically two countries in
Britain you got the metropolitan elites
for one of the better phrase and you
have the rest of the country
particularly up north
where issues like immigration have
become really important and there's no
doubt there's a town I did a political
show for the BBC called question time
the big country show and we did it near
a town near Norwich in the east of the
country and it's a town where in the
space of 15 years they now have twice
the size of population and all those
who've come in to double the size of
population are from Eastern Europe from
when the border was open Eastern Europe
now I'm very Pro immigration but you
can't look at that town and the strain
and stress that this has put on all
their services from hospitals to schools
and others and it's not because the
people of that town of racism there's
been a problem it's because they've just
had this extraordinary change in the
culture of the town that they live in
and no one's really thought about this
or don't want it properly now if you
replicate that around Britain that's why
I'm agree should became the key issue in
the referendum it wasn't about money or
about what we pay the EU it was about
immigration and Nigel Farage and others
hit that very hard I kept telling David
Cameron and his people you're fighting
the wrong battle here it's not about
money it's about immigration you've got
to deal with it and it's really about
assimilation actually more is a bigger
problem so they had a referendum they
got it woke up and discovered to their
shock and horror am i voting to remain
in the European Union I thought the
Europeans a pretty anachronistic
organisation it's not perfect by any
means but actually I prefer Britain not
to think of itself as the Empire it once
was but as a major cog in the big wheel
of the European Union almost the United
States of Europe if you like I felt
there's power in numbers of strength
from volume but the country voted the
other way and it didn't dispose other
way in small numbers seventeen point
four million people voted in Britain to
leave your opinion the biggest
democratic vote in my country's history
and their wishes must now be respected
democracy must be seen to be done and in
the same way that you had here with
Hillary Clinton she won the popular vote
so doesn't count what sorry it's not
about the popular vote its electoral
college is how you get that it here it's
not playing again with chess and
actually playing you know some other
term like checkers and so what
we played chess without playing checkers
Trump played to win chess not checkers
embrace it exactly the same the
remainders or ramona's as they've now
become known
that's simply for three years refused to
accept the result they think that the
people that voted to leave were too
stupid
rather like Democrats here think that
people have voted Trump but just too
stupid understand what they were doing
that's weren't they'd like Donald Trump
and here's the shock for you they still
like Donald Trump so now we're in a
position where Boris Johnson's become
Prime Minister because his predecessor
treason way was a remainer and everybody
knew that and she couldn't have any
conviction about driving a train so much
she didn't want to get - Boris Johnson
does want to get there and the question
is can he now deliver on brexit my
position is I still fundamentally
believe we shouldn't be doing this but
I'm much more concerned myself about the
power of democracy and to see the
people's will respected and delivered on
by the government that's paid to serve
them then I do about getting my vote to
be the right one in other words I might
think is right but the majority in the
country thought it was wrong and this
comes back to social media in particular
the self-righteousness of people that
lose elections now or referendums right
and they say no you know you're too
stupid no actually we have to do this
all over again we should ignore the
result of this election because I know
more than you I'm more intelligent than
you you're stupid people that's where
we've got to and if that is accepted
where every result is simply declared
null and void in this Liberals let's be
honest get what they want democracy dies
so what do you make of the broader
argument that's been made about brexit
and President Trump as part of the same
generalized phenomenon that you're
seeing in you in other countries in
Europe as well I've seen it in Italy
you're starting see it in some of the
Nordic countries that there is a
resistance to a generalized elite people
who want to control your life from top
down who may not take who may sneer at
you it seems to me that populism is
rising because liberals have become
unbearable and I speak as a liberal okay
I in my core I'm probably more liberal
than not although fundamentally I see
myself as a journalist and I'd like to
see both sides of all these
and I can argue both but liberals have
become utterly pathetically illiberal
and it's a massive problem what's the
point in calling yourself a liberal if
you don't allow anyone else time a
different view
you know this snowflake culture that we
know operated in the victimhood culture
the you know everyone is has to think a
certain way behave a certain way
everyone has to you know have a bleeding
heart and tell you 20 things that are
wrong with them and you know I just
think it's all to think eschewed to an
environment where everyone's offended by
everything and no one's allowed to say a
joke you say that joke 10 years ago that
offended somebody you can never host the
Oscars you know so now there's no host
for anything the Emmys now just said the
host either so hosts have gone and soon
every award winner will go because
everyone's a human they're all flawed so
no one can win awards anymore because
they will be no platform before they
even get on the podium so then no hosts
no stars then no one can make any movies
because we're all flawed so no actors
right so suddenly where are we the
Liberals get what they want which is a
humorless void where nothing happens
where no one dared do anything or laugh
about anything
or behave in any way that doesn't see
their rigid way of leading a life no
thanks
so what's happening around the world
populism is rising because people are
fed up with the PC culture they're fed
up with snowflake Guri they're fed up
with everyone being offended by
everything and they gravitate into
forceful personalities you go this is
all nonsense which by the way it is in
most cases so why are we surprised I'm
not surprised it doesn't mean to say
that I agree with all of it but it means
I can understand it and I understand why
the Liberals my side if you like are
getting it so horribly wrong they just
want to tell people not just how to lead
their lives but if you don't leave it
the way I tell you to it's a kind of
version of fascism you don't lead the
life the way I'm telling you to then I'm
gonna ruin your life I'm gonna scream
abuse at you I'm gonna get you fired
from your job I'm gonna get you hounded
by your family and friends I'm gonna
make you the most disgusting human
in the world because he said a joke ten
years ago and that's the attitude we're
now operating in it takes forceful
personalities to rise above it Donald
Trump rose up and went like Godzilla
okay you want to fight I'm here
and guess what millions of people in
Middle America but that's our guy
that's our guy he's the one that's gonna
help us same thing happening across
Europe so one of the things that I
insisted on so we have the other leftist
here's tumblr I always distinguish
between US and liberal specifically
because of this I think I think everyone
cries yeah that's true some of us more
than others but the fact that that there
is a distinction between leftists and
liberals is something that I've pushed
very hard I think that there is a left
there's a rotten left right that's
essence aureus and nasty and then there
are liberals who just want bigger
government and higher taxes and yeah and
more government regulation but
fundamentally agree with basic human
classical liberal freedoms like we get
to have a difference of opinion without
you destroying my business and
destroying my life and boycotting
equinox because right the owner funded
Donald Trump is that the classic story
isn't it absolutely classic story the
equinox and solstice I've noticed in LA
they're all going there all screaming
about it but they're all actually going
there it's really about me otherwise
they'd have to go to the 24-hour guess
what their place is downscale right so
they're not actually gonna they're not
actually gonna deprive their own lives
at the pleasure of SoulCycle Equinox
what they want to do is virtue signal
they want to actually attach themselves
to this and say actually this is so
disgusting I have to scream about it for
like 24 hours I'll move on after that
but in the meantime this poor guy who
decided to have a fundraiser because
he's allowed to in a democratic country
he's allowed to have a fundraiser he's
allowed to like Donald Trump the
president United States and he's allowed
to also have business interests and he's
allowed to have people that come her he
doesn't agree with he probably isn't
agree with half the people more that you
SoulCycle
you know this a liberal fest I've been
down in myself you know that's fine
that's actually allowed in the world
you're allowed to be on a bicycle next
to somebody that supports something you
don't support it's really allowed it's
okay really okay but no you know that he
had to be hounded and everybody had to
cancel their yeah though I mean the
ultimate for me was when Trump went down
to El Paso and he said some conciliatory
things after
shooting and the New York Times had the
audacity to run a headline in the front
page which said Trump urges unity versus
racism which is exactly what all the
radical left and the more overtly
illiberal liberals had been screaming at
him to do and the moment he does it they
then immediately start shrieking on
Twitter for the new one times has to be
canceled as occasio Cortes said they're
now supporting white supremacy so they
have to be canceled two people who wrote
they had done to be canceled everybody
has to basically die because they ran a
headline which accurately reported what
Trump the president had said which may
be riddled with hypocrisy and as a
separate argument which was argued in
the piece by the way and the New York
Times caved and just did a different
headline because the liberal mob had
come after them on social media and
threatened to damage their business
because they had the audacity to
faithfully report what the president
said that day about unity and racism now
what's the result of that the result of
that is it Trump just sings well why am
i bothering you know why am i bothering
he's got a point isn't he why is he
bothering to to to say anything that
modifies people that hated if the
reaction every time he says what they
wanted to say is to scream even louder
whereas what kind of Trump would you get
if you actually gave him cheap credit
occasionally so I say to people give him
credit when he's right and then you
might get a different Donald Trump Reid
art of the deals and you'll understand
the man you're dealing with but they
don't want to understand they just want
to have him as a demonizing figure that
they can scream about all day long does
it makes them feel good well then that
final point I think is the one that
really is telling about so many folks on
the Left a OSI being a prime example if
she put out a tweet thread where she
explained that we are all rife with the
virus that is white supremacy she never
defines white supremacy anywhere in her
tweet threat of course white supremacy
is just anything that she disagrees with
and that she can use a brickbat to hurl
at somebody that that is leading to this
reactionary move on the part of the
right which is okay I'm just gonna just
disagree with everything you know it's
not that you could if people on the Left
refused to acknowledge that they are not
defining terms well and not calling out
their their own when their own do bad
things why would they expect people on
the right not to violate the the game
theory and just we're now in a
prisoner's dilemma where you may as well
Trump in North Korea right so Trump
initially was very bombastic about North
Korea
lots of incendiary tweets right about
little rocket man and so on right and
the left go completely nuts right it had
a you'll be disgusting you're the
president be presidential you know what
do you do you're taking us in a brig of
war what are you thinking about so he
goes and sees Kim jong-un and he starts
talking in a in a upbeat way a positive
way he wants peace as Trump has seemed
to want about everything actually he's
one of the least warmongering presidents
America's had you never believe that
from the rhetoric about him and yet he
did the opposite to what people thought
he would do and so far so quite good
actually his relationship with Kim
jong-un seems to me to be serving the
global interest which is not having a
wall between North Korean America samer
Putin you could argue you know same with
almost everything truck does on the
international stage he seems to be to me
to be a force for peace not war
he thinks Wars are too expensive and you
might say well you know where's the
integrity and that he's just securing a
business go okay but isn't it better
that he's forging peace with these
countries they're wanting war with them
looking how ruinous Wars been to America
both in terms of a loss of life to the
servicemen and women and also in terms
of the enormous cost to the American
economy so why don't given some credit
when he's trying to forge peace why not
encourage him and give him credit but no
he can't win either way
the only answer would trump from his
critics it's a scream about everything
so he can't win he can't actually say
anything that modifies him and that's a
real problem for me you know I've
written maybe 80 columns about Trump
since he first ran as candidate you can
go back and check but I'm pretty sure
probably at least half would be negative
the half would be positive defending him
against people who are refusing to
acknowledge that anything he can do is
actually the right thing so let's talk
about your general view of what
government ought to do so what what
makes you a liberal in sort of not the
classical liberal sense where we where
we agree but the part we disagree what
do you think of them it ought to do well
it should be as small as possible right
I don't believe in massive government
sprawling government agencies or lots of
people doing jobs not quite sure what
they're doing so
public expenditure I think government
should be responsible it should take
action even if it's against the popular
will of the people you're made to be a
government because people expect you to
take difficult decisions and to govern
and the example I would use is someone
like Margaret Thatcher in Britain I
would compare her to the other female
prime minister pear trees in May
Margaret Thatcher is prepared to make
difficult tough decisions but she was a
conservative but Theresa May wasn't she
just wanted to please everybody I don't
believe in people pleasing governments I
believe you are elected by the people
you should live up as far as possible to
the manifesto that you ran on and I
think Trump to his credit has basically
delivered on most of the things he said
he would deliver on and he certainly
tried to you kiddin argue he's been
electing them completely different thing
and so I think that that you know that's
a central part of government is to do
whatever the administration has been
elected has decided it was to do that's
why they got elected you're doing what
the people have elected you to do is
important in democracy so I believe in
that I don't believe in a nanny state
except to the point where the public can
sometimes be stupid too stupid for his
own good you know do I think that
government should occasionally interfere
in the well-being of the people yes I do
actually so where do you draw the lines
around there what's the limiting
principle when it comes to but because
people are very often quite stupid as it
turns out and and you know that and if
you're on the right you think that's the
left and fear on the left you think
that's the right but the truth is that
in personal habits people make lots of
mistakes make lots of bad decisions
where do you draw the line around where
is the government's role in bettering
people's lives because I think this is a
fundamental distinction between liberal
and conservatives cigarette smoking
right most smokers knew it was bad for
them right they know it's bad cigarette
smoking but they want the right to smoke
right so the constitutional right but
they want to have the right to smoke
it's my life fine okay it's your life
but actually what has happened in
countries like Britain and America in
the last 20 years is you know now go
into a bar and be full of smoke if you
don't want it to be that to me seem to
be sensible government you know yes you
are impinging on the right of a civilian
to lead the life they want to lead which
is to walk into a bar and have a
cigarette at the bar but actually if
most people in that bar don't want to
have a cigarette
why should they be subjected to
unhealthy smoke from you in the way that
they would be now is that nanny state by
government to ban smoking from public
places I would think it was the right
thing to do I'm a nonsmoker
I spent the odd cigar but most smokers I
know actually shrug the shoulders and
kind of accepted and there's a kind of
template there I would argue mr. Shapiro
for the gun debate which we haven't had
yet I'm sure we're coming to which is at
what point does the safety and the
health of a lot of people get dictated
to by a group of other people at what
point do you bring them together at what
point do you try and reach a consensus
where the smokers can still smoke or
they can still have a gun but actually
what they can't do is go into a bar and
shoot it up and how do you stop them
doing it it's a fundamental question for
the public health of the country and
treating guns like a public health issue
would be a really smart move for America
right now it might take the politics out
of it which has become so bishops and
polarizing in Glasgow in Scotland had a
huge problem at knife crime a lot of
knife murders young kids mainly white
kids stabbing each other so they treated
like a public health to be and they've
massively reduced knife crime in
Scotland which has been great so you
know nanny state to a point I believe in
people's fundamental freedoms but the
cigarette debate to me was an
interesting one you know drink driving
was interesting debate in America wasn't
it you go about 50 years you can get in
your car and have a few drinks and drive
around and then mothers against drink
driving mad I think they were cooled
rose up after a particularly heinous
drink driving incident and they affected
real change and now you can't do that
now there would be people who still
think I would have a few beers and I
tried okay but you can't actually
because you might kill people and they
have as much right to not be killed as
you do to get in your car with a few
drinks it's fascinating to go a little
bit beneath the surface on this debate
because I think that the debate here is
really about externalities meaning that
the reason that we have laws about not
smoking in public places and there you
would have to distinguish for me even
between public park
which are run by the government and
public establishments which were run by
a private business so my view the
government actually shouldn't be
involved in that if a private business
owner wants to have a successful
business they will stop people from
smoking in their business in most cases
because they're gonna lose business
because most people don't smoke and it's
annoying to have people smoke there but
but take the drunk driving example it's
a better example
so the drunk driving obviously there
they're obvious externalities to people
weaving all over the road and the way
that you actually police drunk driving
is by pulling somebody over who is
weaving all over the road and driving
recklessly so you could theoretically
have a crime defined as reckless driving
without the actual drink being a part of
it per se because you know you if you
drink it you're fundamentally and again
this comes back to the guns debate for
me right
fundamentally you want to stop people
getting in their car drunk that's really
what you want you want to effect a
cultural change in thinking and the
undeniable reality is it a sauce smaller
percentage of Americans now get into a
car under the influence of alcohol than
used to because of the effect of that
campaigning and most Americans accept
that America remember one of my sort of
strange things about the gun debate was
that America's probably the one honest
regulated countries on earth in so many
ways if I want to buy a car I couldn't
believe the amount of paperwork I had to
do I wanted to buy a pet dog my god I
mean you're there all day you know in
other words you know might my my twenty
one but it's now 26 but my twenty one
year also at the time six foot two inch
long hair and a beard with his mate is
the same took them two glasses in Malibu
for a lunch and they wanted a
non-alcoholic beer and they got refused
because they didn't have their ID on
them a non-alcoholic beer because it has
naught point naught naught 1 percent
alcohol in it I didn't even know that
when I asked him to explain why they
when you I'm afraid that's the problem
me they can't prove they're 21 and yet
to be 21 even though a non-alcoholic
beer the same month up in Arizona an
eight-year-old girl went to a bullets
and burgers had her burger then went to
the range was handed by a former Marine
a load of firearms loaded fired them
eventually got handed an Uzi submachine
gun
fired two bullets and lost control and
shot the instructor in the head and
killed him a terrible tragedy she will
never get over that I'm sure her parents
were videoing it on their phone and you
see them suddenly lose control of the
phone they won't get over it
the guy's dead his family won't get over
it what I won't get over is the
extraordinary disparity between this
draconian ruling of my son 8:22 to have
a non-alcoholic beer in LA and this
eight-year-old girl I have a
seven-year-old girl now an 8 year old
girl being able to fire an Uzi machine
gun submachine gun loaded at a gun range
and that remains legal because it's her
constitutional right to do that
that's where I have a problem it's more
the disparity of the way that America
regulates these things well I think that
the the real question there is
criminalizing recklessness meaning that
it's a weird thing to criminalize a 21
year old drinking a non-alcoholic beer
all right I and in the other case
obviously I would think that it should
be criminal recklessness to hand an
eight-year-old girl a gun she's not
capable of controlling and that would be
chargeable in my view you know just
under probably basic negligence but it
wasn't I mean I don't know a particular
case but in my view that should be
although not necessarily as in effect of
banning guns per se because as we've
discussed now several times I think that
the the countervailing view is that
there are lots of law-abiding citizens
who do want to be able to own a gun and
should be able to own a gun I understand
why Americans want to defend themselves
in a country with 330 million guns I
understand why Americans I've heard Bill
Maher say he has a gun right because he
knows he has threats and he knows that
they may come with guns the countries
are wash with guns what I don't get and
this is the same debate we had before
but let me make it probably a simpler
debate for the purposes of this which is
there has been an undeniable increase in
the number of massacres more talking
about shootings of two three people
mass shootings on a grandiose horrific
scale in the last 20 years they are
accelerating for whatever reason and the
firepower that's being used is ferocious
the guy in date in a
recently he was shot dead within 24
seconds of firing his first bullet but
because he had an ak-47 he's able to get
up I think 41 rounds and hit 26 people
maybe more but whom nine died and at
that point I'm like okay surely surely
if you're concerned about gun safety and
you fundamentally believe in the
principle of regulation in everything
every other part of your life right you
have in every part of your life you also
accept our bazoom machine guns are
banned right automatic weapon sure right
so you've accepted regulation on guns so
I say well why can't you go a step
further now except that the preferred
weapon of choice of almost every one of
these Massacre shooters they all use
these rifles but that is the
countervailing question is whether what
we are actually doing here is reverse
engineering the regulation by focusing
in on the mass shootings meaning that
every year in the United States
approximately 400 people are killed with
rifles approximately 1,600 people are
killed with knives about 30,000 people
die of handgun wounds many of those are
suicides so are we focusing in on the
mass shootings because we are focusing
in on the rifles or are we focusing on
the rifles because we're focusing in on
the mass shootings why not why not just
go for a full gun ban in other words so
I proposed a gun bang I said I accept
there are too many guns in circulation
it's not like Australia where they after
the Hobart massacre in the mid 90s they
banned almost all guns from civilians
even then only 1/3 of guns were turned
in in the Australian gun buyback and
that's a lot of guns it's certainly a
lot of gun the equivalent of a would be
a hundred and ten million gun a hundred
percent in the murder rate in America
went down faster after the Hobart I know
the man I mean our gun supply increase
so it's you and I we can argue the DA
new homeowner hour about this there's a
bigger thing which is a cultural
response to these kind of massacres I
found the extraordinary there after
Sandy Hook when 20 young first graders
are literally blown to pieces in their
classroom that America the number one
superpower in the world was incapable of
coming together and finding a unified
response to try and prevent their
happening again of any kind in Britain
we had a direct equivalent of Dunblane
and Scott
but there was a cultural reaction from
Britain from left and right was ever a
political tool that after 16 children
were killed in Dunblane in Scotland in a
similar attack by a lone gunman that
something fundamentally had to change
and we were very draconian as you know
we banned almost all guns from civilian
circulation interesting thing happened
for five years gun crime ticked up a bit
actually and then they said ok we need
to make it more punitive so now it's a
five-year mandatory prison sentence if
you're caught with one of these guns and
ever since that moment John crime has
gone down we have other issues in
Britain like knife crime very serious
problems with knife crime and the
reaction from the British is the same
we've got to stop this what can we do
list limit the amount of knives this
make it draconian to carry a knife or
the street in other words our reaction
to knife crime epidemic now is the same
as our reaction to gun crime which is we
can't allow this to continue
let's bring in laws to change it and
it's not left and right arguing about it
the three things I've always tried to
campaign for here universal background
checks I don't think you're against that
from that it's not in concept although
if it does end with a massive government
gun registry I haven't read right and I
understand why because that comes back
to the threat of tyranny and everything
else right I get that but I've always
campaigned for that I think there should
be a limit on all magazines of 10
bullets I don't understand why anyone
would need more you don't need it for
hunting you don't need a sport shooting
you can do that when Britain if you're a
sport sure you have a licence why can't
you have that here and thirdly I don't
see a need a need in the same way that
only the only possible need for a
machine gun is to kill lots of people
very quickly I think that has now become
the preferred way of using one of these
assault rifles and I don't understand
why the argument against machine guns is
this and the argument against these
assault rifles is a different argument
to me it's the same thing you're just
extending you're extending common sense
so are you talking about a ban on the
sale of a ours and and so-called assault
rifles I which I really also my autos
are you talking about a full Scott
confiscations they're 100 million of
those in circulation I think you would
you would try and do what they did in
Australia you would have a buyback you
know you say look we are gonna try and I
know I know
because at the moment people are so
entrenched about this driven by
political partisan debate but actually I
would appeal to the Kamikaze are you
talking about confiscating a hundred
million guns on the basis of four
hundred yearly deaths no confiscating
asking people to give them up well I
mean unless you're gonna punish I do pay
them I'm gonna pay them and you're gonna
pay three times okay going okay it is
okay nobody's gonna turn that in but you
have to do something it's my point so I
want to continue this conversation about
gun control if you want to hear my
answer and peers this answer and then my
answer to Pierce's answer and all the
rest of it you have to go over to Daley
wire comm and subscribe go subscribe
right now join our club we really
appreciate can hear the other side of
the conversation after this break Piers
Morgan thank you for stopping by we've
got to this more than once every six or
seven years you know what I was waiting
for the cool and I enjoy your podcast
and I like the fact that you'll prepare
to sit with people who you don't agree
with and here you'll prepare a debate
with it's more fun because it's a
cornerstone of democracy without that
there is no democracy thank you thank
you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer Colton
Haas
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex
Zangara editing by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Kamino hair and makeup
is by Joshua alvera pedal graphics by
Cynthia Angulo the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
[Music]